hi guys so Resident Evil 2 it's finally
out and yes I have been the live stream
yet for you
but today I am going to show you the
live stream cut down into the best bits
with some slo-mo scare reactions so
enjoy it's been taken over by virus
okay tell us be honest
drinks did you have no man I barely had
a buzz on
oh come on look just listen all right
she got closer and I got a good look at
her you see her eyes
my wife
just getting good
made some sleep
Nabby
[Applause]
blood
it looks so reminiscent of Resident Evil
7 doesn't it
she's gonna feast waddle my guy
Hey Hey look who it is
no one's around
it could pop early on
and we young
hello anybody there
free ice cream help yourself
something's not right
well I mean there's blood right there so
yeah I would say you were probably right
there's someone here there we go you all
right hi don't move I'll be back for you
okay do I have a gun I don't even have a
gun what it looks cool you have it
Oh
I'll say you need help
stay back sir I got this no no no no
freeze shoot I do have a gun how many
headshots does it take they don't stay
down though right can I find anything
egg loot yeah what is that I don't know
something happened i'll someone hosted
me thank you for everything mr. t
leighton cantaloup anything what is this
a cute
and some lovely ladies oh okay I can't
leave the dude it's cheap well screw
that
okay close it close it okay
what what just random
they're everywhere mom go go aboard the
free ice cream
all right thanks
thank me later when we're safe
come on
hit them Jesus Christ where'd they come
from
oh it's a good thing we found each other
in order to expect anymore
okay
it's very cinematic I like it I didn't
expect it to be like this
Resident Evil 2 the citywide out
Food City police station
three stations not much farther don't
know something
there's no survivors there's survivors
it's a big city it has to be
it's like we're walking from here
[Applause]
mmm does not seem like an appealing
choice okay
you get
now
Oh
it's a burger guy
oh they need to get out of there now but
they could use that explosion to kill
the zombies Oh too late where the hell
is Claire
she obviously got Alber because you get
to praise her so you know Claire Claire
you okay
she's not in there
yeah okay Eddie wait which way is the
station troll la de la la la la
am I going the wrong way I don't know
this way can I climb on things [ __ ]
everybody
there it is the station cool
Oh
dammit how did I miss
all right
Oh Oh Shou sir I did not oh okay this is
go get out of my way go prettiest like
the demo because I got a lot member in
the demos oh I agree Albert Leon does
have a very nice jawline all right
hi guys want me can't have me yes
beautiful
ok let's go inside then
ah
Oh Lu Han last week anybody here ah
thank you I appreciate that
there has to be someone here
[Music]
got to find that guy don't have much
time right so if I remember rightly
there's lychee nothing we can do here
okay let's get let's do this
so much blood
thank you for your subscribe ok
so many assets are medical evil 7 if
that makes me very happy because I'm I
gotta be real what Jesus what doesn't
happen last time she don't know yeah so
um I didn't actually play the overs and
evils cuz I wasn't allowed to cuz I was
too young so I used to go around my
friend's house and play it with her but
we mainly play a business evil 3 that
one is the one that sticks on my memory
the most oh oh as my hand right ok stop
being such a wimp just carry on but I
was gonna say something and then I got
kind of bored with how action practice
it got but then present evil 7 just
brought it back expected for me okay it
was amazing I loved it so much and we we
we play that together guys we raised
money on playing that game for charity
mm-hmm
huh he's gonna get up isn't he one of
these gonna get up and they're gonna get
up Jesus come shoot it Oh
don't get up what oh yeah why aren't I
remembering any of this I've already
done all this before right
i I can't remember what happened
oh yeah
imagine seeing that I think I throw up
so what is that the way out is it like a
keycard oh yeah this is the book book
with the statues well well I am not safe
in here ah Jesus Christ
No get off of me I'm pretty sure that
happened to me last time to open the
freaking door Jesus right all right I
still can't get through here um I don't
know I'm going yeah I know
[ __ ] this I'm Audi y'all [ __ ] I don't
know what I'm going a loss okay I need a
fuse
[Music]
Thanks
thank you for all the farlows you know
Kennedy there was another Oscar I could
yeah
hmm
I'm sure you did what you could
where's this little welcome birthday
thing artists but honestly all you need
to know is that this place will eat you
alive if you want care you know I'm
supposed to start last week and I gotta
polish stay away I wish they'd come here
sooner
it looks in it I'm ready
hopefully you'll be able to find a way
out of this station but officer you
better
he thought this secret passageway might
be the truth
surely if they had a secret passage in a
police station or all the offices but no
lieutenant I'm not just gonna leave you
here I'm giving you an order wookie you
save yourself first I'd come with you
but I just load you down stop
and don't make my mistake
if you see one of those things uniform
or not
I'm not wrinkly oh they know right got
it
yes sir
this game was great
did did today
I'm sorry you have to go through so much
pain I'll watch the arm pain yes let's
go do the lion one now so it's the lion
had that little little twig little bird
line head twig sweet now I can go pop
this one down here
get some herbs I need some herbs like an
aid spray but I'm gonna wait for that
the passage isn't open yet look up my
knife some freakin shank yeah
now I'm all good
which way
oh the only way
no just close the door again like nope
scary okay I've already done this why am
i acting like an idiot
mmm tasty yeah
okay so put some keys that I need to
find
okay oh Jesus thanks for subscribing no
no close it it would be awful if they
could open doors with net with time this
station into a temporary shelter due to
the massive sudden outbreak all police
personnel have been instructed to make
the safety of the citizens their top
priority is we try to accommodate as
many as possible hence why so much blood
one of the refugees attacked us in the
middle of the night resulting in the
death of one officer and injures
injuring three others the president
question was correctly restrained I
believe this was simply a case of
someone snapping under intense stress no
nope nope nope nope I'm over attacked
the station today resulting in a number
of casualties a few survivors were able
to make it safely behind the emergency
shutters but surrounded as we are it'll
be hard for any of us to escape this
place we're not sure we can fix any of
our karma Quitman
so we remain cut off from the outside
world
there was another clash on the west side
of the station around 1:00 p.m. 12
people died and there's only a handful
of survivors left
everything's failing it disarray failing
falling into disarray David Ford okay
that's not good but this is good
[Music]
you can also share any points of
interest in items yeah yeah yeah
does it show you like which doors have
locks and star that would be useful
oh yeah nope nope I'm going didn't I
just say why do you think it opened
doors oh gosh my life what is it hey
there's no burgers in there what is it
with these guys in their burgers oh dude
Wow Jesus how many times through
everywhere I hate this hate this
gunpowder oh okay this is how I make
gunpowder don't permit stare at
gunpowder
seriously okay gunpowder but then this
is how I make it amaz I could hear one
it's down to just me and three others no
weapons no ammo too many skirmishes have
drained us mentally and physically we're
not gonna make it
officer Phillips once suggested we
escape through the sewers
apparently there's a secret tunnel yes
yes I brushed her idea off before but
now it's not standing all that bad yeah
there's no proof there's even a tunnel
or that the sewers aren't infested with
zombies but I don't want to sit here and
wait to die either it's a long shot but
I'm gonna try and find out what I can
about this tunnel Eliot so is that the
guy that we
we tried to save her rookies versus
lemon
hey it's me he's my first assignment yes
I got it
we're putting you on a very special case
for your first assignment your mission
is to unlock your desk oh this is
interesting
okay the key to your success is in the
initials of our first names in put the
letters in order of our desks there were
two locks one on each side of your desk
make sure you get the front them both so
it's B and who's the who's the other one
the initials of our first names
or do you mean like my first name
basically your first has to remember the
fellow officers names but you figured
that out okay so it's everyone else good
luck Leon by the way it might take a
little while to get Scott to give you a
straight answer
damn it scores in the corner between
drops of blood be glad you're not here
rookie oh so they broke that after I am
here now so it's a B oh god there's so
many of them how am I supposed to know
everyone's names oh here we go hi I
heard you coming Jesus Christ why'd you
have to scare me like that he just
killed you out then I told you I don't
have any burgers for you dude right d/f
and be whoa Jesus
they're everywhere I'm trying to solve
this frickin puzzle leave me alone and a
frickin shank yeah oh I was trying to
shank you just going boiling right R P R
P and B and you're gonna get up again
right I've gotta bite that there's so
many though this is N and oh maybe it's
just like an e ne D Ned Ned first names
yeah
Ned yes Ned Ned Flanders and then I got
em Marvis Rita and our Scott
was that what I said Melissa I think it
wasn't something and our yes here we go
cool and look my desk yay I'm happy I
can use my special gun oh my god dude
you just don't stay down and that is so
infuriating I'm gonna explain it
oh oh okay it's a new guy I need to take
it back I need to take it back please
oh my god please have my knife back
thank you
right I am in serious [ __ ] already
oh great please say there's like a
happen here or something oh my god leave
me alone please open the door
oh I mean I don't think he's gonna get
back up uh fights and spare keys it fix
this right now Isis the person you know
who else okay - OH -
I see I see I see the particulate here
is it one and two that's missing then
yeah no we got one
it's 2 & 3 so 1 2 2 1 2 3 we can do 1 0
6 1 0 6 tiny
Oh film okay that's different we can do
1:09 yeah I guess uh mama
oh I don't have a key card go find some
keys now which way which way which way
which way do I go
we load you up get a nice green herb yes
turn the light oh nice oh we've got
money shirt and everything we've got
gunpowder as well that's just good as we
can combine it right this makes yes
yes
God love my mantis is great oh can we
use that filming here oh I think we can
no okay that's weird why a commemorative
photo
yeah
let's go pay that happened to me last
time
press a button to light up its
corresponding lamp light them all to
open the safe the buttons must be
pressed in a certain order pressing a
single button out of order because all
the lights to go out and you'll need to
still see whatever what is they even
referring to I put oh oh okay
so let's try this then I says this one
this one this one this one this one this
one this one this one you
oh that's one of the keys isn't it isn't
it it is alright nice one that's them
let's go back and pop some of this stuff
oh Jesus Christ
oh yeah he's gonna be out here now you
can't see the window oh and I didn't oh
good cuz I put the planks up yes go meet
win okay oh hi hug no words
I don't like it when people touch me
yeah now what indeed it was like looking
everywhere just waiting oh my god this
noise when does some rocks look as oh I
don't like that I love that HD but I
don't like that but I know that enough
shadows they don't like people freaks me
out are there you are little where's an
evil 7 mannequin right there
Oh sweets so many doors have been up
with this key without this key
[Music]
is it ready
Oh mom I'm suspect right now even though
I know I've done all of this is she one
of the things that I need to get to see
she is yeah ah thank you and some guy
scribblings down these corporate
[ __ ] they cut me off after all I've
done for them
an angry Englishman but if that's how
it's gonna be so be it
I'm gonna have a little fun of my own as
the world goes to [ __ ]
I bought it all those filthy pigs up in
a steel pan and got some c4 all I gotta
do is detonated and sayonara suckers but
it's not fun if it's over too soon so
maybe I'll give that one raving loon
something to really squeal about yeah
maybe I'll give him a little toy and
tell him kill the guy next to you and
I'll spare the others what is this what
is this I wonder what he'll do you yell
about justice and pride but how many
times did you go against me your own
superior yeah you're such a good cop
so could you had to die man this is fun
I need some music for this absolutely
bloody crazy okay so if I find some c4 I
can detonate I don't know this is what
he did in here to all these dead people
this is everyone that he killed Anna I
can't write how am I gonna blow up this
I don't think any I don't think I've got
all this stuff
I was looking at it before I moved down
it's still call me Jesus okay jump-scare
okay um okay so this is where I kind of
freaked out last time and I lost my way
and I couldn't get back and then I found
a shotgun where did I find the shotgun I
can't remember this leads to should I go
back I mean if I go back I've got a
possibility of maybe finding the shotgun
but no no no
you can't climb up Kenya I just need to
get anger so I can start to shoot them
they could come out the SADS but luckily
from me they don't seem to be that
bright so I know there's an exit then so
I'm just gonna go down this way
hey great thinking 97th I've got a book
yes I love reading
oh wait I have the key oh yes nice I've
gotta win no way
oh then I sell them from the shotgun so
that's mmm but you know I made it back
yes I knew she'd make it nor yeah name's
Claire I came into town with her you can
get to that courtyard through the second
floor beside with that I'm on it
thanks lieutenant
that's a very good question Jefferson
why there's so many fat zombies amending
the month is like the eel of humans it's
a lot of calories this is very true yeah
so why do I have a book I'm gonna check
out this burger before I put it in piece
of plastic shape that's a bug oh it's
not a real bug it's an art project it
looks like it was being held by hand at
some point now okay
this is another puzzle are there any
doors on this side yeah okay did you
know while we're the home of
pharmaceutical giant umbrella
corporation vacuum City is a vibrant and
dynamic city with a long rich history of
its own and this guide will introduce it
to just a few of the more unusual points
of interest our city has to offer the
building is that in the center of town
wasn't always a police station in fact
it used to be an art museum various
features at the unusual clock tower and
the goddess statue in the main hall
reminds us of the bygone even just a few
blocks in the police station is an
orphanage founded and run by the
umbrella corporation with the help of
generous donations from businesses and
citizens alike the building is known for
its stained glass window which attracts
visitors from around the world nice
I should bid tour guide
whoa thanks for subscribing guys
okay what was that freaking helicopter
yeah oh my gosh you okay oh well one of
the chances you know try going down a
new wall way I had a copter water bath I
got this like double notification on for
you shoot I didn't even realize
so whenever anyone subscribes all like
super chance it's gonna be like see if
you can jump scare me guys see if you
can jump scare me
Claire hey I'll be right there okay yeah
maybe don't scream when you're outside
but the zombies it's not a good idea
Claire it's so nice to see you
unfortunately no how are you doing this
is no time for chitchat I mean that's
good
good luck with your brother no there
don't lose hope I'm sure we're gonna
find him
[ __ ] dammit that what that means it's
gonna bring all other zombies time take
care your stuff
you need to go now
let's get through this both of us
Marvin I've got a situation here I'm
surrounded by zombies bargains you copy
Marvin
I'll be Jesus please may I have my
name's Becky damn it kind of like sped
through this at night when I receive a
because I just started freaking out
yeah you're right the control is the
same from Resident Evil seven losses
that dawn chorus hey I'm a Taurus with
birth Tauruses wish me
okay oh nice thank you
oh boy indeed what the hell I got the
electrical bar just
nice but I feel like this probably still
suck the other I haven't checked out
oh I haven't been to the bathroom
it's gonna be a zombie in here I'm ready
for you I'm ready feet it's just one
monkey overfilled toilet I guess again
here oh cool there's nothing in here I
need to find a key card so I can get the
shotguns we care about right now it's
down here and this way
oh wait this is why I just was gosh you
got some angry zombies out here okay
haven't been in here oh oh great
now we can go to the other bathroom this
is good okay goodbye I'm off see ya
I like how they don't follow me out here
all you have to do is just go around the
corner but they're just like nope
so the best quickest way to get to the
bathroom please
this is the bathroom that I want to go
to okay progress made it
showers on system um it's way too quiet
and yeah I don't like it that was a
little save icon which means bad things
are coming I think
well I might have I've been here I don't
think I've ever been here before
yes a whole new part damn it I'm finding
so many shotgun Amma's still low and go
the keycard
No can I not oh cool cool dude that's
not here Oh flashbang stuff all right
I'm gonna have to chuck some things I
put a CD I'm not often fail to
authenticate the account and set your
dongle kini right oh this is gonna be
like um Resident Evil 7 where you have
to like you can shoot them yeah okay
what do I need a battery for sure a
dongle is another name for USB thanks
Michael as she didn't know that okay I
was gonna backtrack I wasn't I really
don't want to
get my flash I thought I picked up a
flash grenade okay no I didn't let's
just go I hope you enjoyed the video
please do subscribe and hit the bell if
you want to get notified for the next
livestream I will be following up with
more footage very soon and don't forget
if you enjoyed this video please do
leave a like so I need to do more scary
games for you all have a lovely day or
evening bye